Hello again, everybody. This is section 10 of stop-fighting cancer. I hope you're learning a lot as we go through this
Talking about diet the last few weeks and this one we're going to be talking even more about diet and the difference between
inflammation and
Inflammation and
How we really want to strike a balance there?
So let's jump into this right away
So in this section you're going to learn about pro-inflammatory things and anti-inflammatory things and what's the difference now the truth is is that
We don't always want to be in a state of anti-inflammation. So let me explain. So what is
inflammation
Inflammation really so let's say I sprayed my ankle and my ankle swells up. What is that?
Well, that's inflammation. That's swelling inflammation. Well, what it really is is a protective measure
It does several things. It splints my ankle so that I won't break it and I will be stiff and it won't move around
So it protects it from further injury
But it is a
conglomeration of TH1 chemicals
So whenever we're talking about an immune response that you have this immediate
Mutal response, which is the purpose of it is
Buried core with machine guns to kill any pathogen
And then the second part of the immune response is the TH2 they are less inflammatory and they are mainly sent out
Maybe you could say that they're the CIA looking for the enemy so that they could create antibodies against that enemy and tag that enemy
So that then when the TH1 sidefires the Marine Corps are called back in it can kill that enemy
So when I sprayed my ankle, that is really a TH1 response. It's highly inflammatory
Well, why why does it do that? Well, I said it does it to splint that area so that I don't move it and damage that boat even more
Possibly break it, but when you have an injury
Your body sees that injury as a possible
Infiltration of pathogens. Well, it didn't know if you cut your
Your ankle open or not so it sends all this this hyper TH1 response there to kill
What if you damage the skin barrier and through that skin barrier some horrible pathogen tries to enter so now
We got all these white blood cells there ready to kill that horrible pathogen that could have entered there
Well, that did it happen when I sprayed my ankle so that has nowhere to go
So it just swells way up and you're instructed to go home. Put your foot up
Put some ice on it to get rid of the swelling
Well, that's the right thing to do because now we try to
Push it into an anti-inflammatory state. I went into this pro-inflammatory state and it had its purpose
So just like anything else with the body. We don't want to be hyper anti-inflammatory
Nor do we want to be hyper pro-inflammatory. There's a there's a balance there that we strike with so many things in our body
It's about balance
So if I have no inflammation then what is the inflammation in it?
It's the TH1 response. What is the TH1 response? It's the marine core with machine guns
If I have no inflammation then I have no worst machine guns and
Marine core to kill my cancer cells
But if I have too much inflammation, which it could be a whole bunch of other cytokines and chemokines in the area
Then it could resist that very response that we want. So it's about striking a balance
That's what it's all about. It's striking a balance
So we don't want a whole bunch of swelling around my liver cancer and my liver all bulged up
But we also don't what we don't want to have no
inflammatory response there as well
So really, how do you strike this balance? Again, you go back to diet
It's very important not to be eating foods that just cause inflammatory responses because they're irritants. So that's why
You know
Things that might even be good foods can be hyper inflammatory you have to be careful about this
You know I took this list off the internet. I typically don't tell people to go off of a condo
But we don't want to
Eat foods that are inflammatory. Sorry, I'm looking so excited. But the like gluten and k seed and
a sunflower, a sunflower what I thought you said those oils are good for me
Store bought, done, cold, pressed, dairy, meat, eggs, even though some meat might be good for some people
Definitely processed meats. Definitely the more you get into processed foods
And that's why gluten remember wheat is not the same as it was a century ago
It is processed even though it comes right out of the field. It's not the way God created it
These are hyper inflammatory foods. So you don't want to be eating those foods
You want to be eating the biggest thing as an anti-inflammatory diet is greens
so eating greens eating
Eating based diet as much as possible and staying away from anything that is
GMO and stayed away from
Grains grains are your most inflammatory thing that you could have so is
K seed wherever K seed is the protein found in dairy, so if you didn't know it
All right, so that's the best way to deal with
Inflammation you keep that balance in your body is through your diet
So your diet is the most inflammatory thing
I hope you learned something from this section and I'll see you next time